talking about the ethics of digital
medicine in my opinion is both timely
but critical
to do and I think that that this is a
critical topic because we are at the
beginning of with the World Economic
Forum calls the fourth Industrial
Revolution which is progressing much
faster than the three revolutions which
preceded it in case you don't remember
what they are the first one was the
introduction of steam power to mechanize
production the second one was the
introduction of electricity that enabled
assembly lines and mass production and
the third was generally affiliated with
the introduction of computers and IT to
automate production this revolution the
fourth revolution is characterized by
the fusion of the physical digital and
biological spheres in other words its
digitization and AI particularly in the
area of medicine and biology so medicine
in a sense is at a forefront of this
revolution to put the speed and newness
of this revolution into perspective 90%
of the world's data have been produced
in just the last last two ish or so
years and the digital universe is
growing by more than 40% each year or
doubling in size every two years and
this is thanks to three forms of data
machine data transactional data and
social data machine data as the name
hints means that almost anything with an
on and off switch can and will be can be
connected to the internet and generate
data and the new new rule seems to be if
it can be connected it will be connected
so washing machines coffee makers
medical appliances thermometers watches
cars are all generating data about us as
are our transactions like retail
purchases on Amazon and Walmart but any
kind of purchase that you're using with
a credit card is generating data and of
course our social media activity thanks
to Facebook alone we have 1 billion
photos being shared publicly per day so
anywhere you go with an installed camera
in theory your face can be identified
and your actions tracked much of this
data can look like what we would
traditionally find in an electronic
health record what we traditionally
consider health data
or it can be used to derive health
inferences so for example some some
studies have shown Facebook can predict
a diagnosis of depression three months
before a physician would enter into a
medical record so erratic late-night
Facebook post or Twitter posts could be
a hint at insomnia or if your iPhone
detects a lack of movement in a
consistently dark room it could hint a
depression symptom similarly your Google
searches can reveal critical health
problems long before you see a doctor
enter the health system seventy to
eighty percent of US adults
searched the internet for health related
symptoms with sixty percent
searching for specific health symptoms
like itchy rash on your elbow stomach
headache often before seeing a doctor
and a new study in BMJ open shows that
you can correlate searches with
predictions about health so the BMJ open
study was conducted by Penn Medicine and
it shows that patients conduct nearly
three times more health-related searches
in the week before they enter they go to
an ER so this suggests an ability that
online searches can both predict ER
visits but also serious illness in a
part in a person now interestingly
unlike your EHR data these types of
health data are not as well protected by
regulations like HIPAA they generally
fall outside the scope of HIPAA which is
our main key regulation for protecting
individual health data but even HIPAA
data so your EHR data that's where when
you see a physician where all the
information about that visit is encoded
as well as your radiology and lab data
are not as well protected as they could
be and I'm going to spend the rest of
our talk talking about our traditional
types of health data EHR data lab data
rheology data on pharmacy data so when
we think about traditional health data I
think there are four key ethics concerns
we need to keep in mind the first one is
around informed consent
I'm going to argue that I think our
current informed consent model is enough
insufficient and outdated and I'm going
to argue this with seven reasons the
first one is the choice architecture in
which the informed consent is made it's
generally at the point of care and often
when a person is very sick and
vulnerable so it can be for example two
lines in a hospital a very long hospital
admissions document or when you've just
arrived at urgent care and you need
urgent attention not only is embedded
often in many documents it isn't clear
whether you have to sign it can you
cross out parts of it if you don't like
this the part of it or what's the
opt-out process
additionally the informed consent
statement is blanket and it's a static
consent generally covering all uses of
that data in perpetuity it's also very
individualistic sometimes data
particularly genomic data can have
intergenerational and inter familial
consequences and so it's not necessarily
sufficient to get the individual one
person's consent when the data has
implications for many it's also not
temporally bound if you think about one
of the largest aggregators of our health
information they anecdotally shared that
about 20% of the electronic health
record data that they have the informed
consent is over 20 years old it's not
generally jurisdictional it doesn't
necessarily state where your data will
be across states or even country
barriers and not all countries have the
same type of regulatory over structure
as you know this u.s. sometimes it's
better but often it's not but the main
problem with the informed consent
document right now is that once the data
have been de-identified and aggregated
with other people's data you generally
do not need consent to share that data
this is because that's what HIPAA says
if the data are de-identified and
aggregated with other data it's no
longer considered human subjects
research and you don't need consent from
the original
to share it for research and other
purposes HIPAA was written in 1996 when
the risks of de-identification
were much lower than they are today
just to put this in perspective in 1996
we didn't even have Google write that
our major search engine which allows us
to link so many different types of data
together it's very hard to argue that
risks of the identification now are
non-existent and I would say they're not
even minimal so I question whether we
can call research with de-identified
data non-human subjects research and
lastly as was mentioned in the last
panel not getting a proper informed
consent from patients to use their data
in research is arguably very
paternalistic a model and medicine that
we left in the 1980s we're now in a
shared decision-making model in medicine
and patients are supposed to see be seen
as partners not only in the treatment
part of medicine but also in the
research piece and I think that there's
a fear of introducing them for a more
robust informed consent model into big
data and medicine because there's a fear
of introducing friction but that people
may not consent to using to sharing
their data and so you see this whole
movement called free the data the data
liberation movement but this can be
misaligned with individual agency and
shared decision-making I actually don't
think it has to be so all of the
resources that we're investing in
advancing the science of digital
medicine I hope that we invest at least
a fraction of those in getting the
ethics right so for example you know why
are some people are doing this but I
think we should be investing in things
like data visiting empowering that
rather than data sharing
so creating federated models where
different groups get together and create
an infrastructure where people can
access information and query it but not
necessarily receive copies of it and
thereby
protect people's privacy additionally
this is more compliant with the spirit
of HIPPA and the HHS Privacy Rule which
urges covered entities to make efforts
to share the minimum amounts of pH I
data necessarily necessary to accomplish
the intended purpose of whatever the use
is other things is I think we could
really use some interesting technology
to empower informed consent I'm trying
to work out a model like a Yelp model
for consent so let's say you know some
people care about how their data is used
and some people don't so if you don't
care you can just sign the informed
consent document and give a blanket
consent for your data to be used for
research and practice beautiful Anthropy
if you do care about the uses perhaps we
could create a model where you could
consent to categories of uses or if you
want to be consented for every use you
would be notified and be able to vote on
that consent or you could say I'd like
to delegate my consent to somebody else
some other very smart person like the
Mayo Clinic or or Greg over here every
time Greg says yes I'll share my data
you follow what Greg does or the Mayo
Clinic or you could say I want to follow
what the majority does and so we would
hold your data in a data escrow and then
it would be released only upon it but
the majority of people consent so I
haven't worked this model out all the
way but these are things that I'm
playing around with and hope to pilot
seeing with a couple companies the next
big ethics question that's been
circulating and there haven't been good
answers are around who owns data data
data ownership questions and so you see
in parallel with the free the data
movement there's an an opposite movement
of making data a property right and this
movement one of the big leaders is the
my thirty-one movement being led by
humanity Coe I think the ownership
discourse is actually inflating three
interrelated issues and I'm gonna break
them down separately I think the first
one is a dissatisfaction about the
health data market there's this Under
that health data is being bought and
sold like your data in the electronic
health record is being Demick
de-identified and sold to brokers who
are then adding more information to it
and then it's getting button sold a
median of two times per patient and so
there's a lot of money or a perception
that a lot of money is being made around
data about people and that the patient
itself is not sharing in the selling of
the data the profits they're not
shelling sharing in the profits nor are
they sharing in any profits made from
commercial products from using that data
and in the rare disease community people
are pretty upset that they share a lot
of information and data but then they
may not be able to actually afford any
medicines that are developed using their
data so that's where are these apps like
the humanity echo app are coming in and
saying will empower you to license your
data for actually 120 dollars per
company per year and so that you can
make some money and share in this in
this big stream and there's also other
discussions around whether people should
be paid as you know form of labor for
generating data or some royalty stream
payment schemes and things like that so
I'm not gonna actually weigh in on what
I think about the the market issue
except for to say that there's a real
concern that a market could create a
world of haves and have-nots a world
where some could afford to have privacy
and a world where some couldn't I I
don't think from I don't think that that
is necessarily a legitimate concern I
don't think there's any empirical data
to support this and when you generally
look at markets it's the more affluent
and well-off who are able to participate
in markets and if you think of selling
data as analogous to a clinical trial
again it's the more well-off who
participate in clinical trials a
healthier younger white males so I'm not
sure that enabling a patient to
participate in a data market would
exasperate inequalities but it isn't a
concern out there but enabling a data
market could exasperate the deep the
biases that already exists in data about
for example an 80% of our genomic data
is Caucasian data
so if you create a market there are some
worries that you know it's only certain
people will opt in others won't because
of distrust and you'll continue
exasperate the biases that we already
have in our underlying data so the
second piece I think of the concern
around the data ownership issue is is
tied to the consent issue that people
want a little bit more control and
agency around how data about them are
being used and the last piece is people
want access to their data right so many
people are getting access to the data
they can't even access their data it's
it's been said that it's easier to use
your credit card in timbuktu than it is
to take your electronic health record
and port it from one doctor to another
doctor across the street and so under
HIPAA patients have the right to request
and receive their copy of their data
their health data within 30 days in a
format requested by the patient and I'm
sure I'm sure Harlan talked about it
this morning but 53% of hospitals are
not able to provide a copy of their
entire the entire medical record to
patients and most hospitals are charging
for this and it the charge is ranging
from zero to five hundred and forty two
dollars per record did it does anyone
know what the cap is of what you can
actually charge for a copy of your
health record it's not five hundred and
forty two dollars it's six dollars and
fifty cents so patients are legitimately
asking why should they share data when
they cannot even access a copy of their
own health data or potentially any of
the benefits that are derived from
access to that health data like new
medicines that end up very expensive
that was a very patient-centered
perspective now let's look at the
population health perspective other
ethicists argue that under the principle
of solidarity patients actually have a
duty to share their health data because
the effectiveness with which we can
treat one person often depends upon the
quantity quality and variety of data we
can obtain from a great number of
patients in the sense the health of one
can depend on the data from
and so because patients are often
benefiting from health care or
healthcare innovation developed based on
insights from people sharing data it can
be argued that they have a
responsibility to share data to benefit
themselves but also others so this is
actually the direction that the World
Economic Forum is going on I I'm the
lead draft of their new ethics toolkit
for data collectors on the global level
and I always remind them that this
assumes that we have a strong social
contract where misuse of our data is
well governed and and discouraged
however I don't think that that's
actually the world that we live in at
least not in the US it's more
market-based there are so many different
groups that are snapping up data like
land-grabbing but data grabbing you
could think of credit rating agencies
they're one of the largest aggregators
of health data which hints that there's
a market from groups like mortgage
brokers life insurance policies Gena
which protects against discrimination
based on genetic information does not
cover discrimination that can result
from data sharing sufficiently okay and
the last ethics concern that I wanted to
talk about was the risk the inequality
problem and I'm really just gonna gloss
over this because we don't have a lot of
time but there is some concern that
digital medicine could exasperate
existing inequalities as I mentioned
health data tends to be biased it tends
to represent young white healthy males
genomic data eighty to eighty-five
percent of it is Caucasian and so when
we use these data to develop new cures
and therapies new Diagnostics we train a
eye on this underlying data we risk
creating products that only work for
certain populations this has already
happened in diabetes tests you know this
problem very well right voice
recognition from even your Google home
favors males so when I took say ok
Google I have
lower my the decibel of my voice by ten
ten decibels right okay Google yeah will
you please play whatever song I want to
hear facial rec facial recognition
doesn't work for me many racial and
ethnic minorities and the list is just
very long and so that's one of our big
concerns that the biases and the data
can affect the biases of the the
products the algorithms the services
another related one and against to what
was touched upon on the last panel about
value is that data is being consolidated
in fewer and fewer hands in larger in
larger hands Amazon Google and Apple
have a ton of health-related data or
data from which you can derive health
insights just look at Amazon they have a
cloud for EHRs it's not clear whether
they're mining that data in the way that
they mined Gmail for marketing I
actually asked them and I think they
said that they hadn't decided yet how
they were gonna handle that and they
know all of your retail purchases right
are you buying prenatal vitamins I'm
pregnant
Google definitely knew and Amazon knew I
was pregnant before anyone in my family
I had to buy those vitamins Google home
listens to your conversations it
recognizes your voice you're speaking
patterns nor are you upset our amazon
has I guess Alexa food Amazon owns the
whole foods app if you happen to use I
think they're very expensive but if you
order your food on Whole Foods they know
whether you eat donuts or carrots
how much movies movie to spend time you
spend watching movies right did you just
stay home all day in bed out in front of
the TV amazon knows that and amazon has
a new app called zelf has anyone had
heard of zelfs okay it's in pilot phase
Wall Street Journal ran an article about
it they always interview me but I'm
never quoted so zell connects zelf is
very interesting and it again it gets at
some of the issues that were talked
about in the last panel which are
patients are often prescribed not just
medicines but a lot of different
lifestyle recommendations or
over-the-counter products and and often
we have a very poor adherence to
physician recommendations so in comes
Amazon with zelfs and they say when your
physician recommends a list of products
aside from your prescription right in
your electronic health records your my
chart when you open up the the the notes
it'll have a link that takes you right
to Amazon so you can just order all
those products just Amazon by the way it
doesn't take you to anywhere else just
Amazon but all now if you make those
purchases the data are coded itself and
so Zell's and Amazon know that that
purchase came from your electronic
health records so that in a sense is
identifiable health information anyway
the point of this is that these large
companies have a ton of health data and
this consolidation can create imbalances
in power which at a minimum can stifle
competition and reduce innovation which
could limit discovery of new cures and
therapies but perhaps you know more
immediately it could limit pipe
competition which would keep right could
keep prices unaffordable okay so I took
a minimis medalist approached you at my
PowerPoint today
so in conclusion sharing and using data
in medicine promises tremendous benefits
for individual patients and populations
ranging from generating real-world
evidence to help us better understand
how new medicines work for real-world
patients because as we know most drugs
are tested on very small numbers of
young healthy white males it could help
us better track and monitor disease
outbreaks domestically and around the
world develop tailored and personalized
care and treatments and even help us to
touch diagnose and treat diseases like
cancer earlier earlier perhaps even
before symptom clinical symptoms have
begun all of which could greatly reduce
suffering and save lives but we cannot
let these
benefits in my opinion Loras into
neglecting the rights of individuals
especially the right to consent to how
when where and why data about each
person are used including in my opinion
de-identified data but there are large
debates about this and they also should
be empowered to justly share in any
benefits produced from use of their data
we're only at the beginning of the
journey and discovering the promises and
challenges of big data in medicine we're
at the start of the fourth Industrial
Revolution so I'm optimistic we can
channel an auto journey on the ethical
path that maximizes our benefits of data
sharing and digital medicine while
minimizing harms individual both within
medicine and the outside the context and
elevate humanity thanks maybe if there
if there are any questions a great
discussion just wondering you know with
the GDP our in Europe and understand
California data privacy consumer data
Privacy Act I don't know where they are
in terms of enactment what's your
perspective on what's gonna happen adorn
the federal level or the u.s. wide level
with respect to data data privacy
policies and all everything that you
talked about I can't tell yet what's
gonna happen in the US where Yale law
schools actually hosting a workshop on
June 13th where we're going to landscape
the regulations around traditional
health data the HIPAA protected data
domestically and globally and try and
get a sense of where we might be going
in the US I think most countries are the
OECD countries are racing ahead in their
protections of data and not treating
de-identified data as this free-for-all
use they're empowering informed consent
of the individual and then they're
empowering the principle of the right to
be forgotten where you don't just
consent to the use now but you can opt
out of any you can change your mind
later on and pull your data I haven't
seen movements in the US to do that
other than
California perhaps an Oregon and so I'm
not optimistic that we'll be the same
thing and then lastly I think even when
you create these systems there's so much
gaming going on like most countries have
many countries have rules that you can't
move data i'm analysis not a lawyer but
they you know rules you can't move
healthy to outside of their outside of
their their borders and so that's when
they're creating these federated models
that you can still query the data and in
theory gain benefits without actually
shifting the data so it'll be
interesting to see no insights for you
sorry so to follow up on that so you
mentioned just just in California and
Harlan talked about some states that are
that are working on legislation that
would prevent the aggregation for
commercial use of data you you mentioned
a little bit but B could you just talk a
little bit more about is that is that
something that we should be doing more
of or is it a net negative to to limit
aggregation of data and so what do they
do they're limiting the use of the data
by commercial entities so it's States
limiting the use of commercial use of
data of aggregated data I think if
you're gonna limit you're gonna limit
uses I don't think the ownership
structure of the entity accessing the
entity is is the critical element I
think the use is embedded in that
statement seems to be this assumption
that for-profit companies tend to be
more evil and nonprofit companies are
benevolent well I love that assumption I
own a non-profit you know where I'm on
the founder of one you know no margin no
mission affects pretty much every
institution and having been trained by
Larry Lessig for three years
institutional corruption can happen
anywhere so I would again not a lawyer
but from an ethics perspective I'm more
interested in the uses and misuses of
the data and so I would regulate there
rather than the ownership structures of
the users that's that's a very
thoughtful answer I mean you know in a
joking way as we established this more
that corporations are evil but but in a
similar way there's there's there's
plenty of misuses of data that aren't at
the corporate level that that you know
data can be used for misused for
scientific studies again without
permission we've seen lots of examples
of misuse of personal property person to
the tissue you know genetic data for for
research purposes which aren't
necessarily for the benefit of the
individual right thank you for for
everyone who attended thank you for our
guests our speakers thank you to our
sponsors
once again you know Medtronic Stewart
health Haven hub health ventures and and
PRA Health Sciences thank you in
particular to see bit Mike I don't know
if you want to come up and say a couple
things and while you're coming up I want
to thank especially Michele Mantell who
I think you know maybe you know stepped
out of course to to help organize the
the end of the conference but I just
want to say publicly that this would not
have been compiled whatsoever without
our collaboration with cbut and and
Michele specifically who did really all
the work and getting this organized and
putting everything together so thank you
thank you so much and I'd like to
introduce Mike Dempsey who's the
executive director of the Yale for
Center for biomedical innovation and
technology thank you Greg
and this is really the end my primary
job is to thank Greg for organizing this
pulling this all together without him it
wouldn't have happened as he said
Michele is a force to be reckoned with
she single-handedly put this together
and I don't know where she is she's
reckoning with somebody so if you see
her give her a thanks as well of course
the sponsors we couldn't have done this
without you it's amazing
if you look at the diversity of what
we've heard over the last two or three
hours you know we had some huge ideas in
the morning we had some very practical
small companies in the middle who are
making it happen today
and then we wound up with you know some
very thought-provoking big serious ideas
just now so it's something that only the
Yale environment can pull together I
think it's something we should be very
proud of and cbut is thankful for all of
you see if it helps innovators in the
Yale community drive their innovations
to patient impact see bit dot yale.edu
is the website if we can do anything to
help you please let us know
thank you and enjoy the weekend thank
you very much for coming stay dry and
we'll see you next time